[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه اخبار الظهيره
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
الولايات المتحده تكشف عن استعدادها
لاستخدام الخيار العسكري لمنع ايران من
حيازه سلاح النووي
هجوم البريه على سوريا ينتظر اوامر
اردوغان واشنطن وباريس تبلغاني انقر رفض
العمليات العسكريه
السعوديه توقع مذكره تفاهم مع شركه
اسبانيه لبناء عدد من السفن القتاليه
وتوطينها
وفي المونديال اسود الاطلس يسعون لخطف
بطاقه التاهل خلال مواجهه حاسمه امام
المنتخب الكندي
ايه
المتصاعده بينه واشنطن وطهران كشف
المبعوثه
ان الرئيس الامريكي جو بيدن مستعد
لاستخدام الخيار العسكري بهدف منع ايران
من حيازه سلاح النووي المبعوث الامريكي
الخاص بايران لوح انه في حال عدم نجاح
العقوبات والضغط وايضا الدبلوماسيه فان
الرئيس الامريكي سيوافق على استخدام
الخيار العسكري لمنع ايران من امتلاك
السلاح النووي مالي اكد ان اداره بيضا لا
تزال تامل في ان تغير ايران من مسارها
الحالي وان المفاوضات غير المباشره ما بين
واشنطن وطهران توقفت بعد ما قدمت ايران
مطالب اضافيه لا علاقه لها بصلب الاتفاق
النووي مال لشدد ايضا على انه واشنطن لما
تعد ترى البرنامج النووي لايران منفصلا عن
القضايا الاخرى خاصه في ظل ما يحدث من قمع
للاحتجاجات الشعبيه واسعه النطاق في
الداخل الايراني طبعا تصريحات ماله حول
الخيار العسكري تاتي في وقت اختتم فيه
الجيشان الاسرائيلي والامريكي منورات
عسكريه تحاكي هجوما على مواقع نوويه
ايرانيه وابقى ما اعلنت قناه كان الرسميه
الوكاله اضافت ان اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده اجرتها معا تمرينا لمحاكاته هجوم
على المنشات النوويه الايرانيه طبعا
بالتعاون مع شعبه الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه دعانا
[تصفيق]
المشاهدين هذا بالنسبه للطاعات الامريكي
مع النووي الايراني اما في ما يتعلق
بالاحتجاجات الايرانيه ضد النظام في
الداخل الايراني فقط اكد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه اكد ان النظام الايراني يسيء
فهم المواطنين وذلك بشكل عميق وذلك بالقاء
اللوم على جهات خارجيه في الاحتجاجات التي
تشهدها البلاد بلنكن قال في تصريحات لشبكه
سي ان ان الامريكيه قال ان ما يحدث في
ايران يتعلق اولا وقبل كل شيء بالايرانيين
وبمستقبلهم
وبلدهم ولا يتعلق الامر بالولايات المتحده
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي اكد ان احد
الاخطاء العميقه التي يرتكبها النظام هو
في محاولته توجيه اصابع الاتهام الى
الاخرين في الولايات المتحده او في اوروبا
بل يمكن كشف ان هناك خطوات اخرى تتخذها
واشنطن دبلوماسيا عبر المنظمات الدوليه
ومع كثير من البلدان الاخرى لتوضيح كيف
يرى العالم القمع الذي يجري في ايران وفي
هذا السياق قدرت منظمه رانا للحقوق
الانسان في ايران عدد القتلى في
الاحتجاجات الاخيره بحوالي 459 قتيل وذلك
في الفتره بين قطعاش سبتمبر و29 نوفمبر
الماضي من بين القتلى 64 طفلا ومراهقا دون
سن 18 عام و61 من قوات الامن اما بالنسبه
للمعتقلين فيقدر عددهم باكثر من
18,000 شخص وذلك منذ بدء الاحتجاجات في ما
بدات ايضا احكام الاعدام والسجن المؤبد
تتصدر وتصدر على بعضهم وفي تسريبات جديده
حصل موقع ايران انترناشونال على نشره سريه
عدتها وكاله انباء فارس الايراني الرسميه
للقائد العام للقوات الحرس الثوري
الايراني حسين سلامه النشره تضمنت اعتراف
من المرشد علي الخامنئي يقول في انه
الاحتجاجات لن تنتهي قريبا تم الكشف عن
هذه النشره السريه نتيجه اختراق مجموعه
الهاكرز بلاك ريبورد لوكاله انباء فارس
التابعه للحارس السوري وحصلت عليها ايران
انترناشونال وكما توقع مشاهدي القائد
العام للحارس الثوري فان الاحتجاجات
تتواصل في ايران وكما سنشاهد الان تم رصد
مشاهدينا عمليات حرق لصور رموز النظام
الايراني طبعا نتحدث هنا خاصه عن صور
للمرشد علي خامني الذي وصف المحتاجين
مؤخرا طبعا بحفنه من المشاغبين اذا انحرق
صور كما شاهدنا من جهه وادرام نار طالع
ايضا في مدينه بندر عباس مقر للقوات باسيج
هذه القوات التي تدعها مرشد ايران قبل
ايام تبعها نظير الجهد المبذول لقمع
المتظاهرين بحسب ما يحدث يحدث
هذا انا كنت استاذه
[موسيقى]
الاحتجاجات لن تتوقف هذه هي الكلمه
المفتاح في تقرير سري تم تسريبه من جهاز
اعلامي تابع للنظام الايراني تسريب جاء
نتيجه لاختراق لوكاله الانباء من قبل
جماعه معارضه موقع قناه ايران انترناشونال
نشرت تفاصيل مستقى من وثيقه سريه تمت
صياغتها في كواليس وكاله فارس التابعه
للحرس الثوري
وكانت الوثيقه مواجهه لقائد الحرس حسين
سلامي
بوز عمي
قه
لافتا للمرشد الايراني علي خامنئي يتوقع
فيه استمرار الاحتجاجات وعدم توقفها
الوثيقه المسربه كشفت ايضا ان النظام في
ايران يعاني من الترهل من قمه سلطاته
وصولا الى قاعدته
وبالنسبه الى اليد الامنيه للنظام اظهرت
الوثيقه ان الترهل ضرب الباسيج واصفه
للجهاز بغير الفعال والعجز عن التعبئه
لوقف الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
الوثيقه حملت مفاجاه عده بينها تلاعب
النظام بالحقائق ومحاوله اظهار محدوديه
التظاهرات متلاعبا بالارقام من 600 الف
متظاهرا في التقرير السري الى مجرد 40,000
في التصريحات القضائيه
بقيت معلومه واحده وان كانت سريه لكنها
شائعه
كشفت الوثيقه ان 70% من المواطنين غير
راغبين في الخروج في مظاهرات داعمه
للحكومه
ارقام وازمه تفسر توقع المرشد باستمرار
التظاهرات وتشير ايضا الى ان الازمه هي
ازمه نظام وليس مجرد احتجاجات عابره
المزيد معنا من لندن البحث في الشان
الايراني وجدان عبد الرحمن اهلا بك استاذ
وجدان طبعا مظاهرات لا زالت مستمره وهناك
تصريحات من الجانب الامريكي وهنا اتحدث
تحديدا عن مالي يقول بانه الملف النووي لم
يعد منفصل بمعنى اخر مرتبط بالمحيط
والداخل
الايراني وما يحدث من احتجاجات ما لتحدث
عن نقطه رئيسيه تتعلق بان الخيار العسكري
امام بيدن لا زال قائمه او اصبح قائم هل
لم يكن مطروح بالاصل هل نحن نتحدث عن
تعاطي جديد للاداره الامريكيه مع هذا
الملف او لا هو الموضوع انه كل شيء على
الطاوله وبالتالي من ضمنها الجانب العسكري
صباح الخير لك استاذه ميسوء لمتابعيكي
للكرامه اعتقد انه كان واضح بانه منذ
بعيدا على الحكومه هو اعلن بانه لن يسمح
لايران بانزلاق قنبله نوويه حاول احل هذا
الموضوع ظلنا منه يستطيع كما فعلها اوباما
لكن
ايضا النظام الايراني وخاصه بعد مجيء
المتشددين
كما يبدو انه كانت مطالباتهم تعجيزيه
بالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه لذلك اصبح هذا
الملف بالنسبه لاداره
مورد اهتمام خاصه بعد الضغط دول المنطقه
تحديد اسرائيل لذلك همم لجات ادارات بعيدا
الى هذا
عبد الرحمن
لوزير الخارجيه الروسي سردي الى بروفيت
على
معاهده
خاصه بشان انتهائي العهد الانقسام
مختلف العقبات والحواجز دون مائيه
او خطوط فاصل
هو كان انا ذاك يبدو لنا اننا قد وصلنا
الى كل هذه المعاهدات و الوثائق ومن الذي
اعاقه
للتوقيع او لتنفيذ كل هذه المعاهدات
كانت هناك
التصريحات البراقه التي لم تتحول الى
الافعال فقط الى اقواله
والغرب انا ذاكر
او اتبع هذا النهج اللي عدم الارجاعه الى
تلك المواقع الاصليه في العالم وفي اوروبا
لانه الان الاوان
لزوال التاريخ
ولذلك انا الاوان
شويه بتسمو اجنبي
الاخرى في اوروبا وكل هذه التصريحات
البراق كانت تصنع
هو طبعا هناك الفكر الافكار الاخرى
التي خرجت
يعني
1990 حيث وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
الرئيس الامريكي
او الخطر الواقعي يمكن ان يحدث من مجلس
اوروبا
المحللين السياسيين
اقترحوا التخلي عن معاهده وراء الصوت
وعنيته هو بذل المجهودات الهاتف
في اوروبا
مشتركه
على اساس من التكافل
والمساواه والمصالح المتبادله ولم يحدث
هذا
وبتابعه الحلقه الغربه في الواقعه حاول
الحفاظ على هيمنته وقد يعتبر لاحقا
ومستقبلا
امكانيه
لتحقيق يقول لهذه الامور الخاصه بالخطوط
الخاصه التي وخطرا بنسبه لمصالحه
والخطر بنسبه لهيمناتهم
في مختلف في الشؤون الدوليه وبخاصه في
اوروبا ولذلك
هذه الاغراءات الاساسيه الامريكيه
والاوروبيه كل هذا يدل على نهج النيتو
للتوسع شرقا وفكره
منظمه الامنيه في اوروبا
فقد الثقه او اف افقد الثقه من حيث
القرارات المتخذه منذ عام
الغرب بالنسبه للغرب
من حيث المبدا
هو الرابع
من صاحب هذا البيت
هو كل هذا يعود من مفهوم مفهوم القواعد
المؤسس على على القواعد
الدوليه
المشاكل دون تشاوري مع احد معه
وبتابات هل السبب يعوده الى ان الغرب قد
ايه نظره
يوما لتدمير البنيه التحتيه باكملها وبعد
ذلك قام بغزو العراق وتدمير العراق
والبونيه التحتيه المدنيه
وبعد ذلك ليبيا
التي
تعرفونها جيدا اما في ما يتعلقوا بمساله
يوجا ونحن نتذكر هذه الاهداف لان ما اهلات
هذه الاحداث
معايير معاهده الحلس وفي تلك الاوقات
النيتو
او اظهاره
وفتح الصندوق
يا سيدتي اليوم
في تلك المنطقه
اما الان فنحن
الاستمرار من اجل منظمه الامن في اوروبا
وفي تلك الاوقات قد اقترحنا
وعلى ايه حال المجهودات من اولئك الذين
كانوا يريدون الحفاظ على كل هذه الاساسيات
الخاصه بالامن الاوروبيه
على محادثه اسطنبول
بشان الامن الجماعي
الوثيقه الخاصه
وتمت كتابته هذا الوثيقه عندما كانت
معاهده
بعد ذلك بعد الزوال
تلك القوات والمعدات والاسلحه التي تم
التواصل اليهم فقط
في مختلف الصراعتها
تم توقيعها على هذه الوثيقه الجديد في
اسطنبول
حجر الاساسي في الامن الاوروبي ونحن نعرف
مصير هذا الوثيقه الولايات المتحده قد
حضرت لخلفائها
تصديق هذه الوثيقه الجديده
وفضلت الحفاظ او تمديد المعاهده القديمه
وايضا الولايات المتحده قد حاولت
الحفاظ على هيمانتها على
اساس قانوني
طبعا
انسحبت الولايات المتحده من معاهده
الصواريخ
والصواريخ قصيره متوسطه
السماوات المفتوحه ومجلس الامن في اوروبا
تجاهل كل هذه الامور
جديد
دون الادلاء بقيه التصريحات في هذه
الظرفيه انا اقصد رؤساء او قده مجلس
اوروبا او الامنال
الوثيقه الثانيه التي تم التوصل اليها في
اسطنبول ما يسمى المبهوم ان لا احد يمكن
ان يضمن امنه على حساب الاخرين اما فيما
يتعلق
بالتوس- التوسنيه شرقا فكل هذه الامور
تتواصل حاليا والوثائق المنتخب الجميع
بس في مساله ان هذه ان ان الامن يجب ان
يكون
مشتركا ومتبادلا ولا احد يمكن ان يضمن
امنه على حساب الاخرين
على حسابي اضعاف الاخرين
وطبعا هناك ميزه اخرى تتمثل في ان لا احد
يمكن ان تتحدث
لدور فعال او استثنائيه في المحيط الاطلسي
هو كما تعرفونه
وانتم تتابعون هذه الاهداف في السنوات
الاخيره في اوروبا
خالف كل هذه التعهدات
وتوصل النت تقدر
تخلف تحديدا بنسبه لروسه
كل هذا كان محظورا من حيث معاهده اسطنبول
ان الدول الناطقه هي يحق لها في تقرير
المصير في المساله الامنيه الاوروبيه فيما
يتعلق بملاحظه اسطنبول عندما فهمنا
وادركنا ان كل هذه المعاهدات كانت وجوهلت
من قبل الناتو
عينيه الدوله الاوروبيه فقد اقترحنا في
عام 2008
هذه
القانوني يمكن ان تطرح في اطار انه يتساقط
ان نهجوا لتوسعه
كل هذا
ونحن نتذكر كيفيه انشاء الناتو عندما
الامين العام الاول السيد اسماعيل
اوروبا
73 عاما
امريكان
الولايات المتحده تريد
المانيا وانما الاتحاد الاوروبي
باكملهم وبعد انتهاء الحرب البارده
فلسفه الهيمنه تتواصل
وعلى هذا الخلفيه يجب علينا ان لا ننسى ان
نيته
وانا ذكرته
العضواني ضد الصربيا والليبيا
وتدمير الدوله الليبيه والعراق فلنتذكر
افغانستان حيث طوال 20 عاما النيتو حاول
فرده
في هذا الدوله هو خير دليل على ذلك ان لا
يمكن
حل المشكله
بكثره حيث
تتواجد
طبعا هناك
المحاولات امريكيه بشان او في مساله حفظ
السلام
ونحن نلاحظه كم سنه تحاول المتحده
كل هذا خارج
المنطقه الاوربيه
في اوروبا اما الان اكثر بكثير
اتباعنا انضمام السويد وفنلندا تاب عن
الناتو يقترب من حدودنا من حدود الاتحاد
الروسي ويعزز قدراتها لا العسكريه
الهجوميه طبعا تجرى منورات عسكريه مشتركه
وروسيا عدو
رئيسيته ايضا
حتى في عهد الاتحاد السوفيتي اما الان
فتريد التوصل حتى في اسيا
كلها هذا
خلق سافر لمعاهده عام 2010
من قبل مختلف الرئيسيه
رؤساء الوزاره
الحفاظ على هذه الامور
نوفي
قد اقترح مشروع لوثيقه بين روسيا
والولايات المتحده وروسيا والنيتو بشان
الامن الجماعي
وكل هذا الوثائق كانت تنصه على
اندفاع عينيته في جري اوكرانيا الى كل هذه
الصراعاتي مما
تجاوزت جميع الخطوط الحمراء ولغرب كان
عارف كل هذا في هذا اقترحنا همم
لتخلي عن عدم التوسعته والتوسل الى مختلف
فيه الضمانات القانونيه
الامنيه بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
مختلف الدول الاوروبيه التي تشارك في هذه
الوثائق الخاصه بالامن الجماعيه الاوروبي
لم يتسنى لنا همم اجراءه
بار بشان هذه المواضيع وقد سمعنا ان كل
بلد وفي المقام الاول اوكراني ايو يمكن ان
تنضم الى النيترون اما اولئك اما
المكونات الاخرى بشان عدم قابليه التجزئه
الامن على حساب الاخرين فلا احدا او لا
منظمه في
يمكننا تتحدى بهذه الامور الامنيه
بوجودك
قد فضلت ان تستغل الظروف من اجل التصعيد
وهذه الفرصه لم تكن لدى واشنطن فقط وانما
عند منظمه معاهده الامن اا في اوروبا التي
كان يمكنها ان تجمد هذا التصعيد وتعيد
الامور الى مجرها صحيح وتقوم باتخاذ
مجموعه اجراءات صحيحه التي ايضا قد تم
التوثيق عليها في عام 2015
وايد تم مناقشتها في مجلس الامن ولكن فيما
يتعلق بعمل منظمه الامن والتعاون في
اوروبا فان ااه عمل
فان الولايات المتحده هو بروكسل قد اتخذوا
النهج النهج مساعده ودعم النظام
حول الامن بصوره عامه
وايضا فقدان الثقه كما قال مع الدول
الاوروبيه التي يقول بان الولايات المتحده
تسعى لتفكيكها
اخبار الظهيره ولكن بعد قليل
انقر تبحث اليوم التوغل البري المحتمل
لسوريا وواشنطن وباريس
الامن القومي التركي برئاسه الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان الاجتماع الدوريه السادس
والاخير هذا العام طبعا من المفترض
الاجتماع مكافحه الارهاب العمليات البريه
المحتمله في شمال سوريا وايضا الضربات
الجويه التي نفذتها تركيا ضد المسلحين
الاكراد في الشرق سوريا وشمال العراق
الاجتماع سيقوم باجراء تقييمات متعدده
الابعاد للعمليه الجديده المحتمله في شمال
سوريا طبعا وقد افاده البنتاجون ان وزير
الدفاع الامريكي لوليد اوستن اجرى اتصال
هاتفي مع نظيره التركي خلوسه افكار عربه
عن القلق الامريكي بشان التصعيد العسكري
في شمال سوريا اوستن اشار الى ما تشكله
بعض الضربات الجويه الاخيره من تهديد
مباشر على سلامه الافراد الامريكينا
العاملين مع شركاء محليين في سوريا لهزيمه
داعش وبحسب البنتاجون فقد ابل اوستن نظيره
الترك
ورشه القويه لعمليه عسكريه جديده في سوريا
اذا المحادثه هاتفيه امريكيه تركيه واخرى
فرنسيه تركيه قال خلالها وزير الدفاع
الفرنسي لنظيره التركي ان الضربات التي
نفذتها تركيا تؤدي الى تصعيد التوترات
وتهدد استقرار المنطقه والتقدم الذي احرزه
التحالف الدولي على مدى عده سنوات طبعا
هذا فيما يتعلق بمكافحه داعش الضربات التي
يشار اليها هنا هي تلك التي نفذتها تركيا
في العشرين من نوفمبر الجاري في شمال شرق
سوريا على مواقع لمقاتلنا اكراد
الى تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه وتداعيتها
يتواصل انقطاع التيار الكهربائي في
العاصمه بشكل يومي بصوره مجدوله او انقطاع
طارق اضافي هذا الانقطاع الكهرباء سكان
المدينه من التدفئه في الوقت الذي تشهد
فيه العاصمه انخفاض في درجات الحراره
تساقط كثيف ايضا للثلوج طبعا الحكومه
حكومه التكليف من جانبها تعمل على ازاله
الثلوج بمشاركه ثلاثه الاف عامل وما يفوق
المئه من المعدات والاليات دعونا
تساقط كثيف للثلوج في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف في الوقت الذي مازال 25 بالمئه من
سكان المدينه دون كهرباء وتعمل سلطات
المدينه لاستعاده التيار واستقرار جدول
القطع الكهربائي على ان لا يتجاوز عدد
ساعات الانقطاع خمس ساعات في اليوم همم
وسنستعيد جولي بولو محافظه تاريخ
وكل شيء سيكون بخير فهذه اوكرانيا
باي حال من الاحوال سوف نتعامل مع كل
الظروف ولن ننكسر
يعملون بالفعل على ازاله الثلوج من
الطرقات في الوقت الحالي تعمل مئه وسته
وعشرون وحده من المعدات واكثر من 300
متخصصه من هيئه الصيانه الطرق ويشاركه في
الحمله اكثر من الف عامل من الشركات
المتعاقده مع الدوله
انا اعمل عليه ازاله الثلوج الثلج يتساقط
بطبيعه الحال في هذا التوقيت ونحن نعمل
على ازالتها ونظافه الشوارع
وفقا للتوقعات ستزداد كثافه تساقط الثلوجي
والصقيع في المدينه كما ستنخفض درجه
الحراره الى درجتين مئتين دون الصفر خلال
النهار وسالب 50 درجات مئويه في الليل
لذلك تحث السلطات المواطنين على الامتناع
عن السفر في سيارته الخاصه كما يطلب من
السائقين توخي الحذر على الطريق واذا امكن
عدم قياده السياره اثناء تساقط الثلوج اذا
فعادل العربيه كيف
قتل شابان فلسطينيان واصيب عدد اخر بجروح
خلال اشتباكات عنيفه مع القوات
الاسرائيليه في مخيم جنين شمال الضفه
الغربيه القوات الاسرائيليه نفذت عمليه
اعتقال خاطفه في اطراف المخيم لاحد
المطلوبين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في اخبار الظهيره ولكن بعد قليل
الماسك يتوقعوا زرعه رقائق الكترونيه
بادمغه البشر وذلك في غضون سته اشهر
متابعه
اهلا بكم يا مجددا الى اخبار الظهيره توقع
الملياردير الى الماسك بدء التجارب على
البشر باستخدام اداء لاسلكيه تطورها شركته
المتخصصه في صنع شرائح المخ في غضون سته
اشهر ماسك اضاف ان احد اوائل التطبيقات
المستهدفه طبعا هو استعاده البصر وفقا
لوكاله رويترز تقوم الشركه بتطوير وصلات
شريحه للمخ لتمنح المرضى المصابين باعاقات
القدره على الحركه وايضا التواصل من جديد
[موسيقى]
ضمن رؤيه السعوديه 20 30 التي اطلقها ولي
العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان وبحضور ورعايه
الامير خالد بن سلمان وزير الدفاع ووزيره
الصناعه والتجاره وسياحه الاسبانيه ماريا
رياس ماروتو وقعت وزاره الدفاع السعوديه
والهيئه العامه للصناعات العسكريه مذكره
تفاهم شركات نافانتي الاسبانيه وذلك
للاستحواذ وبناء عدد من السفن القتاليه
متعدده المهام لصالح القوات البحريه
السعوديه تهدف مذكره التفاهم الى رفع
مستوى جاهزيه القوات البحريه السعوديه
لتعزيز الامن البحري في المنطقه وحمايه
المصالح الحيويه والاستراتيجيه للمملكه
لاتفاقيه تتضمن توطين ما يصل الى 100
بالمئه من بناء السفن البحريه وصيانتها
وتكامل الانظمه القتاليه مذكره التفاهم
تركز على دمج انظمه القتال في السفن
الجديده وعلى تصميم النظم وهندستها وتطوير
البرم بالاضافه الى الدعم اللوجستي وتصميم
برامج التدريب
ضيا مع نادين مدينه تفضلي
شكرا لميسونه اهلا بكم مشاهدينا لنلقي
نظره على تداولات اسواق المنطقه مع
الاشاره الى انه اليوم اسواق الامارات
ومسقط مغلقه بيعطلات رسميه بالتالي
التركيز على الاسواق الاخرى من السوق
السعودي الكويتي والقطري والبحريني السوق
السعودي اليوم على ارتفاع بربع نقطه
المئويه ولكن لا نزال تحت 11000 نقطه مؤشر
سوق الاسهم السعوديه يتداول قريبا من ادنى
مستوياته بعام تقريبا رجعنا بالايام
الماضيه كنا سجلنا عندنا مستوى منذ نوفمبر
2001 2020 وذلك في ظل التجاذب الذين
يشهدوا على اسعار النفط في ظل المخاوف
بالاسواق العالميه من ركودا اقتصاديه من
جرائم رفع اسعار الفائده على مدار شهر
نوفمبر السوق السعودي خسر 6% كان من
الاسواق المنطقه لانه همم
يتماشى مع اسواق النفط والنفط خسرها سبعه
بالمئه دوليه على مدار نوفمبر وبراند
تراجع 10% على مدار شهر نوفمبر انه اليوم
نحن نقول للجلسات شهر ديسمبر بالتالي
دائما
هذا السوق السعودي خلال الشهر الماضي
خلينا نشوف سريعا اليوم ما هي الاسهم
متحركه بالسعوديه عمل متابع اسانسوبك من
صحراء لاوسط بتوزيعات نقديه ريال ونصف عن
النصف الثاني من هذه السنه لا حقيه لحاملي
الاسم بتاريخ 5 ديسمبر وسهم سبكم الثانيه
اكثر سهم ارتفاعا في السوق السعوديه اليوم
يرتفع 5% فاتح سته فاصل سته بالمئه البحر
الاحمر الورق وبترو رابغ على قائمه الاكثر
ارتفاعا على قائمه الاكثر تراجعا الوطنيه
للتعليم التي انهد شراء كامل همم الحصص من
شركه مدارس السلام للتعليم والتدريب بقيمه
72 مليون ريال دله الصحيه ايضا على تراجع
عليهم من مهدي كذلك القطاعات الدفاعيه عم
شوفوا عليها تراجعات اليوم البنوك والعربي
على تراجع همم طيبه على بعض الارتفاع في
خبر انه تم ترزيه تنفيذ عقد
المقابله الرئيسي لانشاء فندق نوفوتيل
بالمدينه على شركه تابعه
ساكتفي بهذا القدر لهذه الفقره عضو القاكم
مشاهدينا بالاسواق العربيه بعد قليل
العوده شكرا
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي انا واشنطن
تقوم بتجهيز جوله جديده من العقوبات على
كوريا الشماليه بينما تمضي يونج قدما في
تطوير الصواريخ المحظوره وتلمح باحتمال
اجراء اختبار نووي جديد سلف انكشف في
تصريحات خلال مؤتمر صحفي عن ان هناك
مجموعه جديده من الاجراءات العقابيه مقبله
سريعا ومؤخرا رفضت كوريا الشماليه عرضا
امريكيا للدخول في حوار لحل القضايا
الثنائيه وفقه المسؤول الامريكي
روبوتات توصيل الطعام ليست ظاهره جديده في
الولايات المتحده لكن انتشاره تضاعف بعد
جائحه كورونا التي ادت الى نقص في العماله
كانت في داخل حرم الجامعات الامريكيه على
وجه الخصوص حيث مئات الروبوتات الصغيره
من 30 جامعه امريكيه لتوصيل الطعام الى
الطلاب بالاضافه الى مواقع مختلفه في
المملكه المتحده والمانيا والدنمارك
وفنلندا واسبانيا هذه الروبوتات ذاتيه
القياده التي يبلغ طولها حوالي 50 سم
تقريبا تقوم باحضار الطعام لطلاب الذين
استقبلوا روبوتات لتوصيل الطعام بحماس
شديد
الطعام كان قبل ظهور بيروسكورونا وباعداد
محدوده لكن الشركات التي تشغل هذه
الروبوتات وجدت ان الظروف تدفع لزياده
اعدادها خصوصا مع تفاقم الجارحه التي ادت
الى نقص في العماله بخلاف تفضيل الكثيرين
ان يتم توصيل طعامهم ان تلمسه يد بشريه
حيث اكمل شركه ستار شيف للتكنولوجيا
مليونين طلبا لتوصيل الطعام بواسطتها هذا
الروبوت
عن ادراج الباكيت الخبز الاساسي على مائده
الفرنسيه ضمن قائمه الامم المتحده للتراث
الثقافي العالمي غير المادي ليصبح هذا
الرغيف رسميا من ابرز التقاليد والتراث
الفرنسي دعنا نتابعه
سر الموائد الفرنسيه
لحظه كانوا بانتظرها يتجاوزوا هذا الخبز
حدود الموائد الى ليونسكو يعلو الباقيت
الفرنسيه بثقافته الطويله ليفرض ضمن قائمه
التراث الثقافيه العالمي غير المادي
عندما يكون الطفل في مرحله السنتين يعطيه
والده راسا من الرغيف الفرنسيه
وعندما يكبر الطفل فان اول مهمه يقوم بها
بمفرده هي الذهاب وشراء الرغيف الفرنسيه
بالنسبه لكبارنا فان شراء خبز الباجيات هو
وسيله الاتصال الاجتماعي اليوميه الوحيده
لهم
تتصور رموزه هنا لا يقل احدهما عن الاخر
كلاهما للفرنسيه ما يدل على التاريخ اما
للباجيت حكايه صناعه عمرها اكثر من 100
عاما تصنع بحب حديث بينها وبين خبزها
لصوتها دلائل علامه ذاقتها العديده صفحات
فرنسيه لا تخلو من الباكيت طقوس يوميه
لصناعتها ايضا تضم نحو 6
تقليديه لاكثر من 130 دوله فلكل خباز
لمسته الخاصه
الباقيت تعني العصا والرشاقته هذه تاريخ
ومعنا ايضا نعود هنا الى فتره نابليون
بونابرت اجتمعت الروايات على ان خابسيه
جاؤوا بفكره تطويل الرغيف لتسهيل حمله على
جنود الجيش لتحافظ على مذاقها وشكلها الى
يومنا هذا بل لتتوج بطبع ثقافيه وعالمي
بنكهه البساطه هذه المره غذاء السالم
العربيه
الى العناوين
الولايات المتحده تكشف عن استعدادها
لاستخدام الخيار العسكري لمنع ايران من
حيازه سلاح النووي
هجوم بريئه على سوريا ينتظر اوامر اردوغان
وواشنطن وباريس تبلغاني انقر رفض العمليات
العسكريه
السعوديه توقع مذكره تفاهم مع شركه
اسبانيه لبناء عدد من السفن القتاليه
وتوطينها
وفي المونديال اسود الاطلس يسعون لخطف
بطاقه التاهل خلال مواجهه حاسمه امام
المنتخب الكندي
اخبار الظهيره انتهت الان ولكن نلتقي
الاحد القادم ونشره جديده من الرياض
مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]